[Music]
this is the javelin an American-made
missile launcher that has been critical
for Ukrainian forces in repelling the
Russians
the javelin's efficacy especially
against tanks has made it a symbol of
the resistance there's even a story
about Ukrainian parents naming their
children not a joke their newborn child
Javelin or javelina the U.S has already
committed 8 500 javelins to Ukraine last
year President Biden ordered an
additional
653 million dollars worth of javelins to
be sent to Aid in the war effort but
Raytheon and Lockheed Martin the two
primary defense contractors that make
the javelin said that most of what's
pledged from the U.S is existing stocks
not new production and that doubling
production wouldn't be possible until
2026. there is no magic formula to in
the supply chain to accelerate this
the inability of U.S defense contractors
to quickly replenish Weaponry has raised
questions about the capability of
America's defense industry and let some
Pentagon officials to argue that
industry consolidation has gone too far
the challenges with the javelin are a
wake-up call Ukraine has shown that our
approach to acquisition since the end of
the Cold War is has got a downside
the javelin and Stinger missiles become
the poster child for both the effects of
consolidation and indeed the effects of
supply chain problems
in 2021 the U.S spent roughly 800
billion dollars on its defense that's
more than China India the United Kingdom
Russia France Germany Saudi Arabia Japan
and South Korea combined given the
astonishing amount America spends on its
defense industry why can't the U.S arm
the ukrainians faster
the answer lies partially in how America
procures its weapons
this graph charts the consolidation
that's taken place within the defense
sector in the early 1990s the US relied
on 51 primary contractors today that
number is just five Lockheed Martin
Boeing Raytheon Northrop Grumman and
General Dynamics the fundamental reason
that defense companies decided to
consolidate after the Cold War was that
department told them to do so the
department was going to be downsizing in
terms of troops and equipment so
therefore there was a need for them to
to merge to address that that declining
Market there was not a major competition
with a great power the way the U.S had
faced with the Soviet Union so in that
sense if we take shipbuilding for
example uh there was a less of a need to
build major ships this trend of
consolidation took place throughout the
industry tactical missile suppliers
declined from 13 to 3. fixed-wing
aircraft suppliers declined from eight
to three satellite suppliers have halved
from eight to four and Builders of
surface ship ships has dropped from
eight to two the market in the defense
industrial base is very different from
the commercial Marketplace the
difference is is that the government is
both the the customer and The Regulators
but it's much harder than a commercial
marketplace where you have a uh
virtually unlimited Market according to
a 2022 DOD report consolidation has left
the U.S reliant on a small number of
contractors which is stifled Innovation
and undermined price competition a lot
of contracts maybe as many as 40 percent
of DOD contracts are in fact so Source
that's either because there isn't
another competitor or because the
existing manufacturer is just an
incumbent and is such advantages because
they've been doing it so long that
there's not really another viable
competitor
the javelin is a case in point Rocket
motors which are used in Javelin
missiles there's only really two
producers of those Motors those engines
aerojet rocket down and now a unit of
Northrop Grumman it used to be five six
suppliers and now you're down to two and
obviously if something goes wrong at one
of them then that puts a lot of burden
on the other and it just slows down the
entire chain
ramping up Javelin production is also
difficult because of the just-in-time
supply chain scale ing up production for
the javelin is a challenge and it's a
challenge because the way we procure and
the way we produce the the javelin there
are many kind of single and sole source
suppliers for a lot of these components
the companies that produce these they
produce them for a specific contract
need and producing more than that is not
optimal from a business sense the supply
chain challenges in part because of
covet has slowed everything down so it's
actually what it's done is it's extended
the time it takes on average to produce
systems in some cases to two three years
a 2023 csis report found that the U.S is
dangerously unprepared for a major
conflict such as the war with China in
the Taiwan Strait the reality is that in
a war according to our war games
and many that have been done within the
Department of Defense both classified
and unclassified the U.S runs out of key
munitions
like long-range Precision strike in less
than a week of a Taiwan straight
conflict the problem is we don't have
enough not of everything but of some
very specific weapon systems that are
important for the kinds of conflicts
that we're likely to face with China and
that are important to deter those
conflicts from even happening today many
of the defense sectors Supply chains
were built to fight the war on terror
terms of Acquisitions the U.S focused on
components that were important to Target
the Islamic State or the Taliban or Al
Qaeda around the globe some very
specific weapon systems like drones and
didn't require the kinds of stockpiles
of Munitions that are important for a
conventional War the Ukraine war was a
very Stark reminder that a conventional
war is a war of industrial bases
countries involved in a conventional War
they churned through Munitions they
through weapon systems at a much more
rapid Pace than we had seen during the
counter-terrorism campaigns after 9 11.
in response to a request for comment
Raytheon wrote Our industry has
experienced unprecedented supply chain
challenges over the past two years
however by leveraging our scale we have
been able to provide significant support
to our suppliers and we're already
seeing some components like chips and
electronics become more readily
available
foreign
which brings us back to the javelin and
a proposed merger of two contractors
aerojet Rocketdyne which makes Javelin
Motors and L3 Harris L3 Harris and
aerojet which is is agreed to the deal
both argue that by combining and being
part of a bigger company the neojet can
can access resources access extra
investment which will help it perhaps
catch up quicker but some politicians
like Senator Elizabeth Warren disagree
in a tweet earlier this year she took
aim at the proposed 4.7 billion dollar
merger arguing that further
consolidation would undermine
competitiveness within the sector
whoa it's unclear if the aerojet
Rocketdyne L3 Harris deal will go
through especially given that a year ago
the Federal Trade Commission torpedoed
Lockheed Martin's attempt to purchase
aerojet Rocketdyne on antitrust grounds
Lockheed accounted for just about a
third of aerojet sales that was turned
down ultimately by federal antitrust
Regulators they just basically didn't
trust that Lockheed would continue to
make things for other people and note
just for itself L3 Harris is different
it's a very tiny customer of aerojet at
the moment and it will be moving into
areas like missiles where it's currently
just not present so it would in theory
emerge as a stronger competitor to
Lockheed Martin and Northrop Grumman
as War continues in Ukraine and the
threat of other conflicts around the
world Loom policy makers must now
grapple with constraints of
consolidation and a supply chain built
for yesterday's threat environment
foreign